whoa reject nation it's greg al-baqir
it's John over here so today we're gonna
watch the mathematical magician leaves
the judges speechless on America's Got
Talent
this was sent over by quite a good
amount of people before we get into this
we wanted to give a quick shout out to
today's video sponsor lemonade calm
lemony is a fun and easy way to get more
out of the shopping you were already
gonna do by earning cash back on all
your purchases as well as special
coupons too many of your favorite stores
that's right guys lemony works with a
ton of major retailers such as target
Macy's Home Depot Sephora Best Buy Hot
Topic Groupon even the HBO store the
Showtime sword turner classic movies the
list literally goes on and on when you
buy something from any of your favorite
retailers over at lemony you'll receive
a certain percentage of the price back
as your reward for using the service and
right now a number of the store's
partnered with the site are offering
turbo cashback which means even more
savings on the shopping you were gonna
do and as a bonus you can also earn
Commission's each time any of your
French shop when you sign them up to
your own lemony community it's free to
join so hit our special link down in the
description box and let's save and earn
some money together let's do it do it
anyway guys let's watch this heavily
requested video today the magicians yes
my dad and my life so just growing up
one thing to be like him if it wasn't
family wouldn't you have to do what I'm
about to try and do I presume if you do
put on the show in Vegas would be be its
only thing my dream to create the best
magic show basis has ever seen but the
people which travelers from around the
world see good luck
Simon Cowell seemed very nice gentlemen
I want to try and do something that's
never been done at home
and all if you take out me on my ball
folks and I want you just hold them up
in the air can you do that for me judges
I'd like to stand up and have a look at
the audience in today's world all
connected through our cellphones but
what I'm going to show you is that we're
at to her next I'm far deeper level some
you'll notice that if you the device is
still ready yeah
I wouldn't just achieves three of them
to come and join me on stage you in the
right yeah you'll find a song to do say
I need to turn guess for me how many
number one selling artists do you think
Allison's record label 353 alright could
you just type in 53 53 yeah how many
millions of Records you think no but
when she performed the Spice Girls
solo life just every millions 102
multiply times yeah and then 182 okay
okay next up to train guess what
oh it's all but sorry I'm so bad now 19
no no I was born 87 okay get multiplied
okay 87
wonderful okay and then is ready hit the
plus sign what
fantastic now a little buddy told me now
that you've had a lot of girlfriends but
instead just getting tired when we do is
open up us now let's make a round of
guests so we need to close your eyes and
just hit maybe like seven or eight
numbers okay cool equals equals okay
sweet now I just want you to read that
number out for me is that okay okay
ready go free
okay seventy-three men nine hundred and
twenty eight thousand nine hundred and
twenty eight thousand one good guy
Steven right up close for these three
volunteers thank you guys very much
members the number found a number hit
but there's something going on there's
something impossible something beside
and what you guys to see this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow I wish we got to see the part where
they talked to him about it
not your friend
not talented you are going home that
always trips me out man we have a friend
who works at the Magic Castle
David mingkun who did a similar trick
that landed in like with with just a
bunch of random numbers about different
questions and it it was my phone number
Wow
I don't know how he did that it was a
first time I met the guy didn't even
have my phone number
oh he should you should go Wow Simon I
wonder how they did that I mean at first
first negative thing is you know plants
so TV plants it's on TV when all the
judges were in on it it's not real it's
not real but then I've seen actual
magicians do crazy things like that not
on that scale though see there's there's
something fascinating to me about that
kind of a magic trick because certain
things like cards or disappearing acts
I'm like I get it there's something
happening with your your hands or your
palms or whatever there there's
concealing going on but when it comes to
things like numbers and calculations I'm
like I don't know I brought my arms I'm
just I'm just wowed by you and the whole
phones thing too like like getting
everybody's phone to go crazy oh well
that is the act of which I wonder if
this is from a few months ago I wonder
if this guy I could see this guy being a
famous magician one day his personality
seems very sincere I like the youth
aspect I feel like usually when I see
magicians I may have been on TV they're
usually younger but like a real life
when I see magicians there they tend to
be older they've been doing this for 25
years you know you have to I mean so
much of magic is in repetition and
practice if they weren't plants it makes
you wonder how did he pull that off with
like just random questions of like
how many simon cowell thinking question
that was having yeah I mean how old is
the Heidi Klum you know those types of
questions says random scenarios I feel
like what he probably did was he just
recorded millions upon millions of like
pre cards yeah you know and that was
just you know they picked the one that
corresponds yeah so you got to do is
like one number up each time yeah there
could have been someone in the booth who
was like when he wrote it down these all
see the digital the video yeah yeah fake
news not real at the best magic whoa
guys tell me how do you think he pulled
that off are you a magician was it fake
or do you believe in things such as Law
of Attraction and energy and that we are
working under one law that binds us Law
of Attraction and that's what he did he
loved attraction that number because we
all are on a similar wave pattern in
that room let's subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell -
on Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram and
make sure to download the lemony Apple
oh we got one ourselves Jon and I share
each other's bills now go check it out